[Music]
the favorite follows a friendship
face-off for the affection of Queen Han
the film has a really twisted ending and
throughout this video I'll be breaking
down everything you need to know from
the closing scenes there will of course
be heavy spoilers so if you want to go
into the movie with fresh eyes then I
highly suggest that you turn off now but
everyone else
I'm definition and welcome to the
channel where I roon it so you don't
have to we watch is Lady Sarah and
Abigail fight it out on the battlefield
of friendship in order to become Queen
Anne's favorite after Abigail has had a
fall from grace and now is impoverished
and has to resort to working as a maid
we watch her rise through the ranks of
social acceptance all the while being
stopped by the overzealous Sarah played
by Rachel Weis it's clear from the
outset that Lady Sarah does the majority
of the thinking for Han and she pretty
much controls her life and the power
that comes with being a queen it's clear
the Anne while Troy LT has still had a
pretty tough life and you can definitely
see why she leaves the tougher decisions
to someone else over the years and has
had and lost seventeen children so she
now keeps seventeen rabbits in their
place there also exists a war between
France in England which Sarah's husband
is involved in and pretty much has
little interest in the conflict
whatsoever this is something that Lady
Sarah relishes in so naturally when
Abigail looks like she could threaten
this position things do not bode well
for her it's easy to side with Abigail
early on and she comes across as a
kind-hearted woman with little more than
good intentions emma stone is perfect
casting for this role with her big blue
eyes and youthful exuberance and you can
definitely see how someone would like it
Lady Sarah however immediately picks up
on her more sinister side as Abigail
bites people poisons them and is
all-round a bad egg
Sarah tries to have her expelled but
Anne refuses to Anne Anne expels the
lady from the castle grounds instead as
Anne's health fails Sarah wishes to make
one more attempt to regain hands
friendship and writes her a letter
begging for her forgiveness
Abigail however in deceptor slater and
burn
sir after seeing how eager the Queen was
to receive some news from her former
friend abigail lies to the Queen and
tells her that she suspects that Sarah
had been diverting money and this is
believable as earlier in the film Sarah
raised taxes in order to pay for the war
effort and vanishes Sarah from the
country and we never see her again that
doesn't mean everything is all well for
an and Abigail now though and with the
latter pretty much having full power we
see her sick and sadistic side finally
come to the forefront abigail brutally
kills one of Anne's rabbits in the
disgusting way and uses her heel to dig
into it causing it to urinate and bleed
heavily as it rides in pain and
witnesses this and called Abigail to
participate in a massage as they have
done throughout the film however abigail
is now cruel giving pain wherever
possible and we see a vision of the
rabbits hopping around during the scene
this symbolizes the grief and an happy
reminder of how much Anne has lost and
how much her life and choices will
continue to haunt her till her dying day
she takes this out on Abigail's head as
she massages her and an act that was
once sensual and erotic becomes dis
pleasurable like the relationship that
the two are now trapped in Abigail has
been unmasked finally as the wicked
woman she is
however she must also live in submission
in order to not be banished much in the
same way that Sarah was this kind of
confusing submissive life is something
that she always tried to move past but
she knows her place will forever be at
the foot of the Queen and all of her
desires
Abigail escaped one horrendous marriage
only to end up in another and it's a
beautifully twisted ending that shows
you that absolute power corrupts
absolutely
we know that Anne hasn't long left for
this world either and with Sarah now
replaced by Abigail she will deteriorate
faster
Sarah was strict with Anne but she was
being cruel to be kind she stopped her
from having sugar which seemed bad but
it was to help her health under the eyes
of Abigail she binges on cake vomiting
between bites and we really get the
sense that just because you get
something you want it doesn't mean that
it's good for you this too is reflected
and Abigail's quest and the film to me
is about how getting everything our own
way will destroy us to no end so what
are your thoughts on the film did you
enjoy it and what did you take from the
end
comment below and let me know and if you
enjoyed this video then please like it
and check out my breakdown of this
week's other big royal film a Christmas
Prince - this is a channel for people
who are man into movies so if that's the
kind of thing you like it subscribe
thanks again for taking the time to
watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
[Music]
[Music]